hello everybody
how's it going hope you're having a
great day
um here in southwest it's a
very very cold evening um and
yeah i'm i'm still adjusting to the
whole um
losing the the daylights at like 4 30
p.m
it's quite scary to be honest i
um i i like the skies
staying the light as long as possible
but well i can't really do anything
about that
now can i um so
i um i wanted to switch it up a little
and instead of showing full games and
um just instead of trying to do
um just like games individual games i
wanted to try and show
mix it up with some puzzles and the cat
is singing as usual
alright so i kind of want to um
go ahead and just dive in and we can
always
just chat about the position and you
guys know the drill you guys know what
to think about
checks takes moves with threats and
don't forget to evaluate the position
so i think as long as you're doing those
you should be fine
oh kansas city our neighbor awesome
all right so um
i have while you guys are thinking i
might go ahead and
chat a little about some um
some some of the things that are am i
kind of like waiting on this week
um well from semester-wise um
the uh i go to saint louis university
and our
uh semester is almost over like we still
have some stuff to wrap up like i have
so many papers uh but i only have like
one exam that's like take home open
notes
so it shouldn't be too painful um
and i calculated only the 77 on it to
keep my aim
so that's another part
but it's also cancer biology so that's
also kind of a rough one
but yeah so um pretty much here the
university decided that after
thanksgiving break like before 10 second
break so
like on 25th basically next week they're
gonna
just shut down the campus unless you are
staying
like you have a reason to stay like
they're homeless like me
well i live on campus so technically um
so that you can stay but the rest of the
students
are going home for the break of two
months
which is so awesome this camp is going
to be completely closed
uh well completely empty so it'll be
pretty fun for me
but besides that so feel free to share
how your school is doing
and um don't forget to think about this
position
this was actually a little interesting
in the sense of
whites did some really nice stuff but
messed it up at some point so that's one
of the reasons i really liked
show i really wanted to show this
position just because how
white kind of messed it up um
so let's see i'm hoping to have
some responses some suggestions so we
can work
through them so what do you think about
this position
you're now in a ghost university not yet
in about 10 days i will be that will be
pretty cool actually
clues to move it's wise to know but both
of these players are pretty decent
players
um some of the puzzles that i'm going to
show you today i
got from some of the books that jacob
akkard had
i really loved his books so
i really wanted to share these with you
oh yeah you see the cat this is not
nakamura and vl this is i actually don't
know these players this is
resica versus lond lund
and this was a game that was played in
but budapest 2002
so um yeah
yeah i feel like uh it's hard to decide
to shut down but at the same time
some i mean you kind of have to so
puzzle what do you think we should do
now
and i think so um actually no
fragrance it's not birds it's uh it's
someone
that starts with e i don't have the full
last night the world first name but the
beginning of it is e oh bishop is five
yeah
bishop h5 is the best one actually and
um after bishop h5
i think that the problem that's um black
ooh hi tracy ah rook m7 would have been
interesting too
can you have seven bishops five um
you could do that but i think the
problem is that uh what are you trying
to do are you trying to win this game
that's why to draw it because
honestly if you were gonna enter in this
end game you shouldn't have
trouble um winning i mean winning or
losing this but it's most likely going
to be a draw
so that's kind of why bishop h5 is the
tricky version
i see some ruski that i do not speak
but i can detect the alphabet hopefully
yeah uh nobody is resigning
yet just saying uh in the game
i believe blackpool drug f6
because well if not then the f7 knight
is falling so you kind of have to
and white here actually made a mistake
so what what do you think white should
do here
hi it's me i think i've been
in his mirror actually
2013 uh word junior probably
so yeah i think the choice that you have
right now is between rook g1
or rook g4
so the kind of the question is well
which one do you think you should do
um surprisingly rook g1 was not the best
move rook g4 is the best move
because rook g4 when they well then your
king has to go
over here wherever it goes you're just
going to take over here and g8
this is the best way to win it um
so rook g4 is the easiest rick g one
kind of gives that little
um little leeway and
um this is this is still should be
pretty easy for whites to win
but surprisingly white didn't so that's
kind of why
um i wanted to show this to you in the
terms of psychology that
if you have an easy win if you have this
rook g4 and then
discovery check and you're gonna win do
it don't mess around with it
you don't need to try to perfect the the
the um the tactic you can just win the
easiest way
and i'm gonna show you the next few
moves a little faster because i really
do want to get to the position that
white made a mistake
um but for right now what do you think
like how do you think this game is gonna
continue
because this bishop is kind of stuck
here you can't go anywhere
ergo this rook is stuck here so because
you have to defend
the the bishop so what do you think
black is gonna do
and keep in mind that it is black to
move right now
trade bishops that would be ideal i
agree we kind of want to do that
but the problem is that we're not really
i mean the problem is like
um for why sat would be ideal sorry my
bad um
it would be ideal for white if he could
uh trade
uh my live chat went away okay um but
oh 95 yeah i agree might be five go
after the pond why not
so it's a con that you could eat it so
you should go after it
and um in the game well the problem is
if you try to do something like a4 the
knight still goes back
and the pawns this pawn is still falling
so
it didn't really matter so i think it
was white made a good choice to just
play bishop seven free its bishop but
again you see this bishop is still
having serious issues this bishop still
can't really go anywhere
so yeah that's kind of the problem
now i want to take a quick moment and go
back
to the position that white was super
winning
and you can again see how much easier it
is
to win with dirk g4 it's just way easier
way faster
less hassles less chance this for the
opponent
and then compare it to um this position
that we are at currently
why this is still better i'm not arguing
that but i am saying that it's much more
um unpleasant for whites to try to win
this
because how your bishop is kind of just
trapped you don't really have a clear
pathway for your rook or for your king
so that is why
um again my biggest advice is
do the izzy wins don't try to make it
complicated don't try to come up with
some magical
beautiful tactic and if you do that is
perfect awesome
but a lot of great players try it and at
the same time
they they give you the opponent too much
chances so don't do those
yeah okay so
uh i do need to reload my youtube just a
second i'm reading a live chat here but
it's
a little delayed so
all right now it's better much better
and i'm getting an
ad about ryan reynolds that's also kind
of funny
um all right
oh hi kitty yep
the cat was in the background he was
actually he kind of jumped up very
subtly i missed that um
so yaroslav i think one of the reasons
that we kind of prefer
sorry right now it's black to move so i
kind of want you guys to
uh think how can black hold this
position and how can black actually make
plans
but while we're doing that i'm gonna go
ahead and address the
question that yourself asked and please
feel free to correct me if i'm
pronouncing your name wrong
because uh that happens so i'm very open
to it
and i do want to say it correctly so
please feel free to do that and um
so the reason that in that in that in
that critical position
you chose rook g1 uh
i think it's because your rook on f4 was
already doing something useful and
you kind of like um thought that your
rook on each one could be
more of a use and then you kind of
wanted to pick up the rook on f6
so that made sense but that's why i
advise you to hello
uh take your time and actually analyze
before you make these
moves and yeah hopefully it should
reduce the um reduce the
chances of getting your opponent's
runaway chances um
a5 maybe so the thing is
white wants to try and free this king so
maybe this king could come up and do
some funny stuff
because well black's king is kind of
just
just cornered basically so this bishop
is not going to be doing much
this king is not going to be doing much
white's king wants to do much
right so knight f5
take away this e3 square no more king e3
gmp she has joined the analysis yes you
see grace that's
he graced us with his momentary presence
his majesty yeah maybe i should change
his name and
just call him a king or something at
this point
um
thank you yeah i love hearing how cool
my cat is please
keep this keep this going she's pretty
cool
i love him he's so nice he
he meows a lot too but yeah um
okay i think
a5 is on the to-do list but
the problem is if you were to play a5
then your b6 pawn would become
quite weak and i don't know if we should
do that yet um you could
think about potentially but just still
working on
just getting this king into the game you
can't really go
from the clean side and you can't really
go from the center so you kind of have
to
go from the king side and
um in the game they did the little dance
with their pieces that it was not very
useful anyways
and why this is still trying and
struggling and just
trying to throw in some checks but i
think
um here was a critical another critical
position
so i want to take a moment and think
and ask you guys what do you think we
should do
we have two choices of rook g1 which the
king most likely will go back
to either f a two or f six
and still your bishop is going to be
pretty useless or
uh you could just go to rock h7 and pick
up d7
i'm saying a lot of rick h7s yeah let's
go with rick h7
king takes or takes knight b5 all right
so
knight b5 you still have a problem your
two of your pawns
are under attack which one do you think
you should save
which one can you can you save basically
uh i agree arthur i think that white is
still doing pretty fine but white has to
play this still accurately white can't
just
um white can't just
just play whatever he wants
and it's that's cold
um
so
yeah i think king d2 is the easiest way
to go about it
because you can't really save your a
pawn push a four takes and picks up a4
right
so you have you kind of have to move
your king now the other question is can
you just go like e3 and want to go
on f4 e5 and i think the answer is
simply
um maybe because you could actually take
uh take knight to come back to e5
attack or knight could take c2 attack
i mean that's another way that black
could sorry
white could go about it but i don't
think i mean i don't think there's
anything wrong with this for whites
right
we simply trap the knight that should be
fun enough
um maybe it might take c3 is a little
bit
better replace a7 and maybe just uh
knight b5 ideally
black wants to free his king as well so
if you give that check that was pretty
awesome for black
but i think that rookie 7 knight takes
a3 maybe or it takes up here
be five maybe
or take yeah i think this would this
would most likely
be um just a fair fight at this point
yeah they're a lot the rook is attacking
a lot of the ponds that is true
um yeah so i think that's why
you wouldn't really want to play king e3
uh uh
here you'd kind of just want to go candy
too and just keep your palms control
but at the same time your king is kind
of far away from the center
so yeah
these are just uh some some things to
consider before you make your choice
now obviously knight's going to take on
eighteen takes a7
check take on c3 and um
now why did you move what do you think
we should do
[Music]
so this is actually very interesting how
people think that this is
like winning forward this is not winning
for white this is this is
better for white but it's very um it's
not even that much better for white it's
like
white has better chances because of the
activity but
it it still is a kind of a rough road
ahead
so rook a6 is interesting
but the problem is if you play rook a6
uh it's the same ideas that if you were
to play rookie 7 and if you played rook
a6 the king on
g8 kind of frees up so
i kind of prefer rookie 7 so that the
king is
still on the back rank
and yeah your k7 e5
you take this b4 logically rook b6
and now black to move what do you think
black should do
this shouldn't be too hard to find
so
yeah exactly knight a2 should be easy
enough
and after knight a2 well
now you're uh as as um
black you are still holding pretty
nicely but i think the biggest problem
for white is these pawns so
as white you kind of have to figure out
what what are you trying to do because
if there is like a c3 and if
this pawn of c2 somehow falls it's not
really um it's gonna be pretty
pretty hard to control um
again that's also far ahead like
if you played king f4 um
this is still pretty doable because i
was thinking what maybe b3
take and then c3 but there is rook c6
so this still holds um
yeah so there are a lot of things to
think about
i mean yeah you can try knight c1 trying
to throw in some checks
but why this is the black is still doing
fine
sorry what is it still doing uh much
better than black
so these pawns are okay but they're not
really um they're not really that
dangerous yet did white have to allow
this
um no to be honest no
i didn't have to allow this but white
kind of got
forced into it because wife decided to
eat some of the pawns on the seventh and
sixth rank and so i kind of just
um ended up here but
i think the best way to continue now
was maybe just king f4
because i don't see any media threads
so uh c3 is dangerous no question there
but it's still no immediate there's no
immediate threats
yes yes if c2 falls then yeah that's
going to be pretty scary
but still not an immediate threat so
my point being that why should have
played aggressive but white's trying
because you can just play
king d2 and then black king got out
and white continuously helped him
just trick a6 like a6 i don't think
that's a good idea
simply because you are giving white the
chance to
sorry you're giving black the chance to
actually consider pushing these pawns
so now like to move what do you think we
should do
and um since i already gave up a tiny
hint
that white messed this up i think you
guys
haven't can make a um informed
guess on where white started messing it
up
exactly b3 now b3
white took c3 would have been a
would have still worked for white but
this check would have won immediately
because after b3 if take there's c3
and after c3 um this knight d2
knight b4 is coming up again white
should have played king e3 something
like c2
and this situation we still would have
most likely been a draw
um because the knight is kind of having
trouble escaping
so this would still be a draw for
white whites could have hold this
position but white make a mistake and
play with king d3
and whoops now this is not the draw
anymore because the knight is free
again in this position the knight can't
really run away
whereas in how it happened in the game
the knights did actually manage to run
away
so another big lesson that we could
learn from this position
is even here even when you realize that
oops i've messed up
try your best to figure out what's the
move that the position needs
like not not not that you realize you
messed up that's not the question
there have been so many games that i
realized that i messed up but i try to
find the best
move that the position needs not the
best like ah this looks better this blah
blah
another thing that i actually learned
from reading the fisher book
um 16 memorable game one of my most
favorite books
i definitely recommend it i don't know
where you can buy it i remember just
club had
many many copies but i don't i don't
want to
give false information i don't know
about the current state but
my point being that one of the things
that i learned from
fisher in his book was how
it is actually understandable and
acceptable that
when you have such a great position for
so long
pretty much all this position from
bishop h5 white had
advantage maybe uh maybe he didn't do
the best
moves but he had advantage clear
advantage and
he managed to convert it he managed to
free the bishop he managed to get the
rook to the seventh rank
he managed to cut the king so
when you have advantage all the game and
you suddenly
find yourself in a position that you
realize oh
i might not actually be able to hold
this advantage anymore
so that's actually a very like
very critical um point that you need to
just take a step back
take a moment drink a sip of water
just just take if you can't take 30
seconds just like get your mental back
to yourself because
you have to reevaluate the position you
have to figure out what you're fighting
for now
because up until now you're fighting for
a win
but now in just a span of two moves you
start to mess it up
so you have to figure out what's the
best position
uh what's the best way to save this
position
and in order to do that you have to
realize that you are trying to actively
save it you're not trying to win it
anymore
so just trying to make that transition
in your mind it's a very
um it's a very delicate process
and you should take that just even if
you don't have time even if you're
playing on
um seconds just take two seconds and
just talk to yourself okay
i messed up take a deep breath and start
thinking again
so that's one of the biggest things that
i learned just
having messed up so many beautiful
positions
and having talked to other players who
have done that
so learn from my mistakes and don't do
that yeah
yeah exactly instead of having yeah yeah
i'm already in the chat and you guys
are very correct oh good to know
fisher's book is on amazon
um yeah you don't exactly want
to lose your book i agree with that
daniel and all right
so uh with on that note i'm gonna go
ahead
and show you the next puzzle and gm
fishies here as well
so i don't know if you can see the cat
but
oh yeah you should be able to see the
cat
sitting right here angled cute
um i did some of the games that i really
wanted to
show uh in the sense of how i saved it
i already showed it on our twitch
channel but
uh those videos don't really stay so i'm
gonna ask
uh and see if there's a way to maybe um
use that clip to share a link here or if
not
uh next week i'll be sure to
show some of the games that i had just
in this topic
it is why to play yes and again i do not
know these players
and um i um
i could type it in chat and see if you
guys know it
and the cat's name is literally cat but
justin farsi
called peachy
oh he got offended
so uh i sent the the name of this
um game in the chat
asked for a messed up during a
tournament no but he almost
made me um he was being very distractive
in the last round of the u.s
championship
as the eclipse kind of made it to the
internet too he was
his patience was kind of running thin i
guess that's how
the americans um
and um he was just like meowing all
around and he was like
dumping stuff from the table to take it
to get attention
and he was just like basically coming
close to me to petty when i had one
minute
and i um yeah i had to take some middle
eastern measurements
of um to
yeah i uh not not my proudest moment
but i had to um put him on the floor and
just like
hold him there so he wouldn't like with
one hand like holding the cat with the
other hand
playing the the tournament yeah that
wasn't
my yeah that was a drop but i won that
game so it was kind of fun
i get to talk about it if i lost that
game though there would be
no tuna for him for two months
he loves tuna okay yeah i
i named my cat cat you can think it's a
very romantic way that there's no other
cat in the world for me
that could be it i don't know i i just
like the name peachy
all right um who is my favorite world
champion
i really liked fisher um
but i did not exactly enjoy his um
his nothing joy sorry i didn't i
couldn't relate to his
um loneliness and the mental illnesses
that he was facing
so i i don't have a i like a bunch of
them like i wish i could combine them
all together and have that one person
i really do like capablanca but again i
don't know
much about him the way i know about
fisher i love that
like there's so much information about
the future that we can learn about him
and i think that
uh i watched queen's gambit finally so
if you want to chat about it
make sure to talk with me about it and i
think that the queen's gamut was
somewhat like a
female fisher the way that the the whole
movie was
um going was very similar to
fisher uh just
the female version
and all right so anybody has a fun idea
on how to play this game
i i've been looking at the chat and i
have i've seen some ideas
chess related but i haven't really seen
anything um
anything uh concrete and not
the correct move yet oh yeah yeah i
actually did finally watch
breakfast at tiffany's and how audrey
hepburn called her cat
cat that was that was a little
interesting but no
i feel weird naming my cat human names
um easy maybe i don't know that much
about judith's personality but
i from what i know i kind of wish that
they showed like
more like a judith poker's um family
story
because three successful sisters that
basically dominated the
the world uh the chess world for so long
i think that's what made and they like
they grew up in a family they didn't
have to be in an orphanage they didn't
have to
um get take pills or alcohol at such a
young age to
be able to play chess to my knowledge so
i feel like that would have been a
better story but again i don't think it
would have been as dramatic
so i get the cinema
uh point of wanting to make it dramatic
but still i i feel like it's
it wasn't as relatable to me because
yeah just i i love the games though i
love the chess bars i love the
outfits i absolutely love the actress
the storyline was pretty cool too just
the start of it i didn't really enjoy
that
and all right finally yaroslav thank you
thank you
yes queen take c4 queen take c4 bishop
e5
and um rook c6
i guess it's possible
uh but if rook c6 there's knight d4 and
i still want to pick up c6
if castle i'll still pick this up i'm
just attacking your queen
i'm still attacking there's so many
attacks and white is actually much
better
white has enough compensation and some
uh if king f7 just take rookie one
and this is still the queen is very
misplaced the bishop
on e7 is very weak the king on f7 is
even weaker than that
what are we talking about today i
believe
that we are talking about some positions
that
they're not exactly tactics they're a
mix of they're actually real games so
there's like a mix of
tactics and strategies which is perfect
blend
to in my eyes and
um yeah so what if queen c6
obviously we're gonna take it but how
are you going to continue so
white has advantage that's not the
question how are you gonna win this
and while you guys are giving me some
answers yes you're also talking about my
cats that's the
subject of every every
hour that i'm awake actually my mom
calls to see the cat
it's like i mean i love it but
i want to talk to my mom but the pc gets
to talk to my mom basically
um
yeah i i think you're correct hammer
tapping i don't think it was about
judith
they might have added some stuff to it
to
uh make it more um movie-like and more
successful as a as a movie
uh mini series but yeah
i would really love to see that um just
like that
sister power of pogers something like
that
more as instead of drugs and addictions
because
i don't know too many chess players that
are actually addicts or alcoholics
they might have they might enjoy that
type of rock and roll chess
chess tournament like you go to
tournament you drink you do stuff blah
blah
depending on the country you're at but i
don't think they're dependent on it the
way that was
so i think that was a little um scary
now
people not like imagine um parents
wanting to put their children
in chess and they're gonna be like huh
well i guess my kid's gonna get
po popping alcoholic butt will be very
successful in chess
all right let's start this beautiful
journey together
so yeah i don't i don't encourage
addiction i don't encourage alcoholism
so
uh to me that was a little rough to
watch that that just that part the rest
of it i absolutely did love
yeah deadbeats for russian kasparov did
you know kasparov was a
was given cancelled on the chest stuff
in this
ah good one addicted to chest alright so
um
still what do you think we are gonna do
uh in this position how are we gonna try
and win this
ah rook d4 i think it's pretty awesome
rfd4
but the i think one thing that we gotta
figure out is this knight because this
nice job is kind of done right now and
d5 could potentially be something that
could happen because the knight on e6
would be under attack
so let's just do knight f4 we could bomb
to put that knight on d5
attack b4 attack e7 well
you're attacking my g2 pawn i don't
really want to lose this so let's go
work g4
e3 makes sense open up some back rank
and all right so why to move what do you
think we should do
uh yes chess guru there are different
coaches that you can reach
i do know that the coaches in us charge
pretty
um pretty heavily to my knowledge
so um
i don't you can try to figure out
on the leeches or chess.com coaches i do
know that they have a pretty uh
detailed uh
list of coaches i want to say but that's
not true a lot of the coaches are not
there i'm not there
um so i kinda like it i think it depends
you could just try to contact the chess
club for beginner lessons and
i think the chess club beginner um
charges like 25
something like that i don't know for
sure so feel free to just call the chess
club
uh chess club and ask them for their
level and prize and all
all right so i think the question we're
trying to figure out
is shall we try to exchange the stroke
or
because this trick is pretty active and
defending b4
so im is higher than fm yes the only
thing that i
am is lower than is gm
im is also higher than wgm which is kind
of hurtful
but its true oh yeah i think we can
afford to disconnect is better
take you take it and yes this bishop
gets to go to b6
but your position is still is better as
white
because um well your knight is really
strong
and if you could just eat like one of
these pawns or try to get h7
what if you can just eat one of the
pawns that will help you create a
passport that would be
very um just really awesome
so
yep let's go with dirk f1
um rushing one would have been strong to
try and go to e7 but rook f1 is kind of
more straightforward i think
you just want to eat the pond king e6
you eat the pond
and now another question
shall we eat age 7 or enough eating and
maybe we can just try to develop a
little or push some ponds
so um pipe and chuck uh that's a
that's an ongoing debate that i've
thought about as
i've heard other title players talk
about it but the problem is that
um there are not enough women chess
players in the world
to just kind of like delete the titles
like
um like the ratio
is one two hundred and some countries
one two thousand one to ten thousand
for one women chess player and like
thousands or ten thousands
mailchimp player and that's not fair for
them to
lose that title and um uh
that's something that's just not fair
but i understand
and somewhere in the u.s for us it kind
of doesn't make sense why would there be
a woman title
where there's where like there shouldn't
so yeah that's an ongoing conversation
but hopefully um
yeah i i i'm a little tired talking
about this topic
i've been talking about it for a long
time and
it's there's no clear solution so it's
just kind of one of those things that
i'm trying to accept and be somewhat
okay with
but okay i like knight h7 yeah this one
either seven you wanna go rock f6
and bishop v7 makes sense you're trying
to stop that and you're also trying to
trap the night right
the knights you can't really move that
much
yeah now what do you think we should do
here as white
and i agree brian clark that is a very
good point that until the gap in the
numbers close or at least gets
a little more um a little less hurtful
actually because it's kind of hurtful to
see um
and that's one of the things that i
think uscf is doing a lot
jan shahada is doing so much that since
chess love is doing so much with
organizing women's events organizing
just
encouraging younger girls to play having
like
chess in schools stuff like that just
bring more awareness to chess
so i think that's actually a very
interesting thing who knows maybe in 50
years we'll actually
be able to see that so
yeah there's still hope and so don't get
me wrong i don't have that
uh i don't have a negative opinion on
the queen's gambit i absolutely loved it
i'm just saying like there could have
been some things that just when you are
in the chess society
it feels um a little that it could
it's not so realistic but again it's
also a fictional um
movie because no woman has ever been
that strong
unfortunately so um overall it's kind of
a mixed emotions
is there a really famous youth chess
youtuber
um have you checked other content on the
chess club the
desktop video series
and yeah g4 should be the best one
yeah i think g4 is just kind of the
easiest way to go about it
um g4 you kind of want to push and i
don't think
there's anything wrong with that so d4
g5
d3 g6 d2 and
in this position black just try to
make it a little harder for white
but um the thing is if black could take
on g7 then your knight is falling so
what do you think you should do here as
white
i think the thing that um
i think the thing that the queen's
gambit does is
it simply brings a lot of awareness to
chess and it shows that
it's not just a a game that men can play
even though it's a male-dominated
society it's still something that girls
can do
and i do really i do absolutely love
that and i think that's a perfect thing
but they are bringing that awareness
so i have overall i appreciate it
is there a famous female chess youtuber
that is
uh i think anna rudolph
i remember her but a lot of the um chess
people
do streams on um twitch
so i don't exactly know if they do it on
youtube as well
but i always remembered anna rudolf was
very involved
ever since i remember actually
yeah night effects kind of something you
have to do
and you free your night you're trying to
go after the b4 pawn
try to save the night and as long as you
don't blunder your knight you should be
fine and yeah
you got it um okay yeah that's kind of
the
one of the other puzzles that i wanted
to show and let's try to get a few more
so the thing is in the previous puzzle
instead of actually playing queen e4
which is actually pretty beautiful
um the best move was not queen before
now can you tell me what
is the best move we just we just went
over this puzzle and we just looked over
the end game that's resulted from queen
takes c4 queen takes e4 bishop b5
point c6 bishop takes c6 rick takes c6
and i believe knight f4
so now
oh yeah i did see tanya started
streaming i think i saw that
announcement on you on her instagram
um
oh not necessarily rook d5
oh no not my g7
also my camera is again throwing in
green shades on me oh my god i gotta get
that
fixed before my next tournament ben
feingold is
funny and he's very educational i think
he's perfect for uh beginner slash
intermediate slash
like any any any um strength
as long as you have that time
and he's pretty awesome eric rosen is
pretty awesome too
i think he does more on twitch though
yeah bishop bishop b5 much easier the
whole idea is if you were to play bishop
c6
i could just play rook d4 so we kind of
get to a similar end game but
instead of you having that zero g8 g4
i just start picking up your pawns so
that's kind of the improvement on the
end game
all right so i really wanted to uh again
similar to the previous game that we saw
with bishop h5 and then rook g4 or rook
g1
this is the same this is kind of similar
on which one
do you manage to beat your opponent
easier in all right
um let's go oh this is a cool puzzle so
why to move what to do
this is a little too cool actually
yeah of course jonathan he's very
awesome too
i've seen some of i i haven't seen all
of the videos on the san francisco
channel it's just way too much uh but
i've seen occasional some of the videos
and
i haven't seen a video that i don't like
and it's just very um it's lovely
there's so many different people who do
it i think this idea of gym residences
brings such a great diversity i see some
of the older videos that like
my coach alejandro used to do and i'm
just like whoa
it's like 10 years ago and this guy
still looks the same
yeah 100 i think he's never gonna age
it's very fascinating
duda um he has always been a great
player i don't know
i don't follow chess that closely i
don't let me rephrase that
i don't follow um online games that
closely unless there's something pretty
cool that i'm trying to prepare for you
guys
because um i i have wait i told you like
semester is closing up i'm dealing with
mcat
and it's way too much studying
oh thank you brian clark i remember
you've been around
for most of the pandemic and that's been
pretty awesome
i hope you've been enjoying it ah thank
you you are sloth b6 yeah b6 is the best
one now
what you have to calculate is not bishop
e1 exactly
but something like first of all um the
three moves that you got to calculate
are first what if you take because take
is um
it makes sense it's reasonable because
knight c5 and b7 are coming
um other move that this big class white
wants to play this knight c7 maybe
bishop f2 to stop it
and the other move is well i mean if you
just play something like that it'll be
real fun right that's pretty ah it's
actually pretty mate
so you have two moves to think about
what if
black plays bishop of 2 or what if
black plays bishop sorry the rich takes
a7
so
so
oh can ferris will be world champion
that is a great question
uh i think he has a lot of potential so
if his potential
is nourished with the right group of
people and right
coaches and write support he does have
the
the the potential but
there are a lot of people who have
potential but they don't get the
necessary support so we'll see
what did i ask i asked what do you think
about rk7
and bishop f2 so those are the two moves
that
would be reasonable for what to try and
do so what do you think which one do you
think is better
all right it's work f7 take king of
seven
uh-huh um sorry rookie seven beat
and king a7
um bishop c6 i see that
and um
f2 that's the thing with the draw
well let's let's take a quick look at um
rook a7 take bishop e1 maybe
to stop the bishop c6
and what about this how can we survive
this
so arthur i don't think that we're
talking about mate i don't think that
was the goal of this position
the goal was kind of just to try and
figure out well
what does this position need yeah we
gotta play a8
and then we gotta play king a6
surprisingly
that's the funny part because if you
play king b6 there's bishop a5 and black
actually does win this
so you have to play king a6 queen
bishop b5 and just to just to think how
freaking this is it's really freaky what
game is this this is actually
simply a puzzle this is not a i don't
think this is a game
because um the way that jacob agart
labeled it was chess and israel 1999
i don't actually have a game for it
so yeah as i said the most of the things
i'm
showing tonight is inspired by jacob
aguard's books
he's a great chess player and a great
writer i do recommend
his books so
it again it doesn't exactly mate because
simply
i mean white black could just you know
do this and not make it mated
but uh if black wants to keep fighting
there is this
queen f3 which we can still
throw this really wonderful stalemate on
it
so i absolutely love this game i am
going to
just continue enjoying this game but
let's take a quick quick
back look at what is bishop f2 so you
don't have knight c5
now what do you think we should do as
white now
uh i really did enjoy talking about
other players like judo and
lyriza i think they're both great
players um others
seem to have a lot of talents so
hopefully he can find his way
and just keep
ooh knight growing bishop do you want
there you go yeah
you're gonna attack this little guy i am
this could be just take take and check
and just surviving it like this
throwing bunch of chicks defending and
black can't really win this
but nor can white so this would be a
draw but this is this isn't why this
puzzle was pretty
this puzzle was quite pretty because of
rook a7 and czech and f2
and k6 which you basically allow your
opponent to make a queen with check
and then you have this pretty awesome
stalemate
right all right let's try to squeeze in
one more hopefully
actually my bad um not
one more take a quick peek one move
before that
on how white in this position
put b6 and then if bishop f2 bishop d1
we could have looked at this bishop e2
with bishop v2 is actually wrong
bishop f3 is best as we just said
right um
yeah but if you played bishop e2 bishop
e2 is wrong
because uh simply rook takes a7
and uh the rook gets free and your
knight on v6 is still pretty useless
and if the king gets to go to a7 then
your knight can't really check it to get
away remember
in uh the previous line that i just well
in the same line the previous game
that i showed you king c7 we had this
knight d5 and 93 idea that we don't
right now and after king a7 uh
this just you lose your knight unless
you're going to lose
so
that is kind of why it's good
this one that is kind of why after b6
bishop f2
um
it's not bishop b1 is bishop d1 is
doable but we just saw it
and we don't we didn't really exactly
enjoy the idea with f2
and then bishop e2 that wasn't the
easiest way to go about it
so that's kind of why instead of playing
bishop d1
we could simply play something like
bishop e3
and the idea of bishop b3 is that we
just want to go to d5
and we should have two knight e5
that is also um that is possible
but i don't like that we would like we
would
lose the b6 and then f2 is coming up i
don't really like that idea
so i think if you're gonna do anything
you should go for this bishop e3
and just go over the bishop d5 and if
not bishop d
if you can't find bishop b3 then you
should definitely go for bishop d1
so bishop b3 if uh take you simply can
take
and if you get into that position the
awesome thing is no more rookie two
so you have just bishop c4 you get the
knight you put the knight on e3 and this
is a drop
yeah this is gonna be a draw it's really
hard for black to actually try to make
cross
progress but if bishop b3
um what if something like king c6
yeah this is actually a pretty great
puzzle i think i understand
underestimated how much i like this
but yeah so uh just try let's try to
wrap it up what if you king goes to c6
so we don't do bishop d5
i see some pretty cool ideas
um i don't think my d5 is that cool idea
i think knight v8 is the easiest way
he tries to run knight a6 check and i
want to throw in knight c7 but i can't
do it just yet so i have to do bishop
uh d5 check and then b7 and that
actually gets quite the full point
hopefully instead of trying to do
something like knight c7
yeah i think my v8 light a6 was actually
pretty cool
yeah good job guys this was actually
pretty rough puzzle
yeah arthur you're correct that that
actually does work wait why do you say
it doesn't work
bishop d5 king d5 b7 a brook a7
oh i think um oh i think you were
talking
about when the knight was not on a6
that's why we have the knight on a6 so
we won't get checked if you take i'll
just make a queen
yeah uh if you try to do the same here
with bishop d5 that's why it fails
because of yeah exactly
check and take okay good good
yeah i'm glad this um we got to look at
this beautiful puzzle today this was a
very rough one
so if we had to sprint through it a
little i don't know why we
always end up at that situation at the
end of the class
like we run into some really interesting
puzzles at the end of it
um so i i really wanted to show this
mainly for the still mate point but also
i think it's a nice warm-up
for your uh next hour with the center's
chess club
and which is going to be pretty awesome
and games
so um i'm gonna
go ahead and log off but make sure you
stay around
and watch the end game class that's
going to be pretty awesome
and game is always pretty awesome right
it's going to be some weird stuff that's
you're going to be really confused so
it's going to be great
oh you you'll be great all right um
i will see you guys on friday on twitch
so have fun and stay healthy
bye